Kids can be so confident about what they know and what they think they can do. And then they get tested. One of our producers, Elna Baker, talked to somebody who was tested like that as a girl. Hey there, Elna.
孩子们对自己的认知和能力往往充满自信。但随后，他们就会面临考验。我们的制作人之一埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker），采访了一位小时候曾经历过这种考验的人。你好，埃尔娜。
Hi, Ira. Yeah, so the person in this story, her name is Molly. And Molly grew up in an apartment complex outside of Houston-- lots of families. And the parents, they worked long hours, some multiple jobs, which meant that this complex was really run by the kids. They had total free rein. And they did all sorts of things that you could only do if there were no adults around.
你好，艾拉（Ira）。故事里的主人公叫莫莉（Molly）。莫莉在休斯顿外围的一个公寓大楼里长大，那里住着很多家庭。父母们工作时间很长，有些人甚至打好几份工，这意味着这个大楼实际上是由孩子们管理的。他们完全自由。他们做了各种各样只有在没有大人的情况下才能做的事情。
Like what?
比如什么？
Like there was this four-lane highway up behind the complex, and the kids would go up to the highway.
比如大楼后面有一条四车道的高速公路，孩子们会跑去那儿。
And we would play leapfrog across the highway.
我们会玩在高速公路上跳背的游戏。
This is Molly.
这是莫莉。
And we would wait until a car came. That way, it would be kind of scarier. If we could see headlights coming, this is when we were like, all right, now's the time to leapfrog.
我们会等到有车开过来。那样会更刺激。如果我们看到车灯亮起，那就是我们要玩跳背的时候了。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
I know. And then, sometimes, those lights would be a police officer.
我知道。而且有时候，那些灯光是警察的。
So they would turn on their lights and turn around real quick and start speeding toward us. And this is when it was fun because we were like, we're ditching the cops right now. And we would run and back into the complex and just spread out and hide wherever we could-- under cars, in bushes, in truck beds-- and watch through the cracks.
所以他们会打开警灯，迅速掉头向我们冲来。这时候就很有趣了，因为我们会觉得，我们现在正在甩掉警察。我们会跑回大楼，分散开来，躲在任何能躲的地方——车底下、灌木丛里、卡车货厢里——然后从缝隙中窥视。
Molly loved hiding. So her and her best friend, Ariel, they come up with this reason to hide all the time. They decide that they are spy detectives, and it is their job to sort of spy on everyone in the complex. And at the time, they're 10, 11.
莫莉很喜欢躲猫猫。于是她和她最好的朋友阿里尔（Ariel）总能找到躲起来的借口。她们决定自己是间谍侦探，监视大楼里的每个人是她们的工作。那时，她们才10岁、11岁。
And they're tiny, too. They're these tiny girls, so they can fit everywhere. They would go into the laundry room and hide inside the machines with the door cracked, so they could eavesdrop. Or they would hide in the laundry room trash cans.
她们个子也很小。她们是瘦小的女孩，所以哪儿都能钻。她们会溜进洗衣房，把门掩上一半，躲在机器里面偷听。或者她们会躲进洗衣房的垃圾桶里。
Which is disgusting, but we didn't care.
虽然很脏，但我们不在乎。
So they're hiding and spying on people all the time.
所以她们一直在躲着偷窥别人。
Yeah. What's funny about it is, everywhere-- if you were a kid in this building, you never actually had-- you'd think you had a moment of privacy. And then you turn, and you'd hear them giggling, or you'd know they were there. And there they are.
是的。有趣的是，无论在哪儿——如果你是住这栋楼的孩子，你永远不会有——你以为自己有一刻的隐私。然后你一回头，就会听到她们的咯咯笑声，或者知道她们在那儿。她们就在那里。
Did the other kids in the complex know that you guys were spies?
大楼里的其他孩子知道你们是间谍吗？
Yeah. Yeah, because they always knew who was stalking them.
知道。因为他们总能知道是谁在跟踪他们。
So all of this is going on for over a year. And then Molly and Ariel, they leave the apartment complex one night to go to a sleepover. This is 2005. They're 12 and 13. And when they get back to the complex the next morning, they see this swarm of cops.
这一切持续了一年多。然后在一个晚上，莫莉和阿里尔离开公寓去参加过夜派对。那是2005年，她们分别12岁和13岁。第二天早上她们回到大楼时，看到了一群警察。
One of the other apartment kids immediately, as right as we got out of the car, ran up to us and was like, someone just got murdered. And we were like, what? And he was like, yeah. And the cops are looking for you because somebody said that you saw it.
其中一个公寓里的孩子，我们刚下车，他就立刻跑过来说，刚才有人被谋杀了。我们问，什么？他说，是的。警察在找你们，因为有人说你们看到了。
And we were like, what do you mean? We just got home. We were at Sheridan's birthday party. And he was like, the apartment below me, somebody stabbed somebody else. And because the kids knew we knew everything, they were like, yeah, Molly and Ariel know. They had to have seen it.
我们说，你什么意思？我们刚回家。我们在谢里丹（Sheridan）的生日派对上。他说，楼下有人把别人捅了。因为孩子们知道我们无所不知，所以他们就说，是的，莫莉和阿里尔肯定知道。她们一定是看到了。
Wait, did they actually see it?
等等，她们真的看到了吗？
No, they didn't, but the kids were just so confident. Molly and Ariel, they see everything. So the kids are like, just go talk to them.
没有，她们没看到，但那些孩子就是那么笃定。莫莉和阿里尔什么都能看到。所以孩子们就说，去找她们谈谈就行了。
And so what happens?
后来发生了什么？
And so they hear these police are looking for them. So they ran up to the cop that they know, Officer Cook, because he lives in the building.
她们听说警察在找她们。于是她们跑去寻找她们认识的库克警官（Officer Cook），因为他住在这栋楼里。
He was like, hey, I've been looking for y'all. And we were like, OK, yeah, our friend told us, but we just got back from a birthday party. We weren't even here. And he's like, oh, OK, well, y'all stay away from this area. And we were like, OK. Yeah, that's not going to happen.
他说，嘿，我一直在找你们。我们说，噢，是的，我们的朋友告诉我们了，但我们刚从生日派对回来。我们根本不在这里。他说，噢，好吧，你们离这儿远点。我们说，好的。是的，那是不可能的。
Because they think they can solve this.
因为她们觉得她们能破案。
Yeah, they think they can solve the murder.
是的，她们觉得她们能破获这起谋杀案。
Wait, how old are these kids again?
等等，这些孩子多大来着？
They're 12 and 13.
她们12岁和13岁。
OK.
好吧。
But, you know. So in order to solve this, they're like, OK, what do we need? We need to know the facts. So they go back to the boy who told them about this in the first place. And they're like, what happened? And he's like, OK, so it happened right underneath my window. And they're like, let's go see.
但是，你知道。为了破案，她们想，好吧，我们需要什么？我们需要掌握事实。于是她们回到最初告诉她们这件事的那个男孩那里。她们问，发生了什么？他说，好吧，事情就发生在我窗户下面。她们说，走，去看看。
So we run up to Daniel's house. And we look down into the fenced bottom floor apartment courtyard area, and we just see blood. And we're like, oh, my God. This is real. This is not a rumor. This is not a joke. It's real. There was a puddle of blood.
于是我们跑到丹尼尔（Daniel）家。我们向下俯视围起来的一楼公寓庭院区域，只看到血。我们说，天哪。这是真的。这不是谣言。这不是开玩笑。是真的。地上有一滩血。
So we're like, we have to help the cops. Obviously, we need to be involved in this because we're spy detectives. So we run back down to Officer Cook, and we're like, so what happened? And he was like, this woman stabbed her boyfriend, and he died. And she threw the weapon, and we don't know where it is.
所以我们想，必须帮助警察。显然，我们需要参与其中，因为我们是间谍侦探。于是我们跑回库克警官那里，问他发生了什么。他说，这个女人捅了她的男朋友，他死了。她扔掉了凶器，我们不知道在哪里。
So they hear this, and immediately, they're like, we're going to find this murder weapon.
她们听了这话，立刻想到，我们要找到这把凶器。
And it's so weird because, I mean, that's impossible. How do you find a murder weapon? But we just knew we were going to find this weapon. This apartment complex is our world. So we know every hiding spot because we've hid stuff there.
这太奇怪了，因为这不可能。你怎么可能找到凶器？但我们就是知道自己能找到。这个公寓大楼就是我们的世界。所以我们知道每一个藏身处，因为我们曾经在那里藏过东西。
Oh, it's all coming together, all their hiding.
噢，她们的躲藏经历全都派上用场了。
Yeah, they either have hid stuff there, or they've hidden there themselves. And so they go sit at the top of the stairs. And they just start brainstorming. They're like, all right, where could this murder weapon be? Could it be in the ditch that runs behind the building? Could it be in the field out back? And then Molly has this idea.
是的，要么她们藏过东西，要么她们自己躲在那里。于是她们坐在楼梯顶端。她们开始头脑风暴。她们想，好吧，凶器可能在哪里？会在楼后的水沟里吗？会在后面的空地上吗？然后莫莉有个主意。
Let's look on the carports.
去车棚顶上找找。
Why?
为什么？
Well, think of it as, you have something of your sibling's, and you're going to hide it because you don't want them to have it. Well, we would throw it up onto the carport because we knew that there was no way they could get it once it's up there.
嗯，你想想，如果你有兄弟姐妹的东西，你会藏起来因为不想让他们拿到。我们会把它扔到车棚顶上，因为我们知道一旦扔上去，他们就没法拿到了。
So the carports, they're like 10 feet high. You'd park under them.
那些车棚大约有10英尺高。你会停在下面。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
And it's impossible to see the top of them from the ground, but you can easily see it if you go to an upstairs apartment.
从地面根本看不见车棚顶，但如果你去楼上的公寓，就能轻易看见。
Ah.
啊。
And Ariel's apartment overlooks the carports that are closest to the murder.
而阿里尔的公寓正好俯瞰着离案发现场最近的车棚。
So we run up Ariel's stairs. And her bedroom window looks to the back of the apartment, where the carports are. And we are looking on her carport, and we see a knife. And we're like, oh, my God. That's it. That's the knife she used to kill her boyfriend.
于是我们跑上阿里尔家的楼梯。她的卧室窗户正对着公寓后部车棚所在的地方。我们看着她的车棚，看到了一把刀。我们说，天哪。就是它。这就是她杀她男友用的刀。
And when you first saw the knife, were you just shocked?
当你们第一次看到那把刀时，你们是不是震惊了？
Yeah, we were so shocked, because we were like, there's no way we just solved this that quickly.
是的，我们太震惊了，因为我们觉得，没道理我们这么快就破案了。
That is really quick.
这确实很快。
Yeah, so quick. I mean, if you think about it, police had been working on this for hours. And this is the very first place that they looked.
是的，太快了。我是说，如果你想一下，警察为此已经忙了好几个小时了。而这竟然是他们查看的第一个地方。
So we run down the stairs back to Officer Cook, and we're like, there's a knife on the carport above Ariel's apartment. And they're like, what? And we're like, yeah.
于是我们跑下楼梯回到库克警官身边，说，阿里尔家上面的车棚里有把刀。他们问，什么？我们说，是的。
And the officers are like, OK, yeah, yeah, we'll get to that in a minute, kids. And they do. They come upstairs and look out the window. And to their shock, they see the murder weapon. And then they send an officer out there with a ladder to climb the carport.
警察说，好吧，好吧，孩子们，我们一会儿就去处理。他们确实去了。他们上楼往窗外看。令他们震惊的是，他们看到了凶器。然后他们派了一个带着梯子的警察去爬上车棚。
And I remember the officer had one of those bags for evidence. And he picked it up, and there was blood dried on it. And he put it in the bag. And they were like, great job, girls. And we were like, thanks, you know? We're here any time you need us.
我记得那个警察拿着装证物的袋子。他把它捡起来，上面还有干涸的血迹。他把它放进袋子里。他们说，干得好，姑娘们。我们说，谢谢，你知道吗？你们随时需要我们，我们都在。
That is exactly the way the dialogue goes in the Disney TV version of the story.
这听起来简直就像是迪士尼电视版故事里的对话。
Well, the girls, for them, this is this huge triumph. I mean, everyone in the whole complex finds out that the girls solved this murder.
对她们来说，这是一个巨大的胜利。我是说，整个大楼的人都知道是这几个女孩破获了谋杀案。
We were so excited. We were so proud of ourselves because we did it. We proved we could do it.
我们太兴奋了。我们为自己感到自豪，因为我们做到了。我们证明了自己能行。
When she got older, Molly would tell this story. And when she did, she would play it for laughs. But then, something happened recently. She was telling it to one of her coworkers-- also from Texas. And they're doing this thing where they're swapping only in Texas stories. And she gets to this one.
莫莉长大后常讲这个故事。讲的时候，她会当作笑话讲。但最近发生了一件事。她正在告诉她的一个同事——也是德克萨斯人。他们在聊“只有在德克萨斯才会发生的事”。当讲到这个故事时。
And I think it was more her reaction to it that made me realize, oh, that's not actually a funny story to tell. That's a serious thing that happened to me. I'm a child, and I just saw a puddle of blood on the ground and found the real knife that killed this real human being.
我觉得是对方的反应让我意识到，噢，这其实不是一个好笑的故事。这是一件发生在我身上的严肃事情。我还是个孩子，我刚在地上看到了一滩血，还找到了杀死一个真实人类的凶器。
It was being able to see that blood on the knife, that's what stuck with her the most. And also, they sent people in to clean up that puddle of blood with bleach. And she was going to remember the smell of that and watching that, the blood spread all over the pavement.
能够看到刀上的血，这是最让她难以释怀的。而且，他们还派人来用漂白剂清理地上的那滩血。她记住了那种气味，看着血迹在人行道上蔓延开来。
And where were my parents, you know? Did we ever have a conversation about this? Did they even care? How do you just solve a murder, and there are no adults around? How do you leapfrog across the highway? I mean, it doesn't mean I had a bad childhood, but I would never follow any of the rules that they followed as parents.
我的父母当时在哪儿呢？我们有谈论过这件事吗？他们甚至关心吗？怎么会有人在没有大人在场的情况下破获一起谋杀案？你们怎么能玩跳背游戏穿过高速公路？我的意思是，这并不意味着我童年过得很糟，但我绝不会遵循他们作为父母所遵循的任何规矩。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, on our program, we have stories of stuff that happens when the grown-ups are not around. Or they are there, but you wouldn't know it. They stay so fully on the sidelines, leaving the kids to figure things out on their own, sometimes with incredible resilience and inventiveness and good, levelheaded judgment-- sometimes not. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在我们的节目中，我们将讲述当大人们不在场时发生的事情。或者他们虽然在场，你却根本察觉不到。他们完全置身事外，让孩子们自己去解决问题，有时展现出惊人的韧性、创造力和冷静的判断力——有时则不然。请继续收听。
Act One, "Magically Malicious." So this all started pretty small. A bunch of little kids left alone in a classroom, not even that long, before it became a schoolwide, citywide fiasco that the kids had to make sense of. Lilly Sullivan tells the story.
第一幕，“魔法恶作剧”。这一切起初只是小事。一群小孩子被独自留在教室里，没过多久，就变成了一场需要孩子们自己来解决的校级、市级的闹剧。莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）来讲述这个故事。
You know those really vivid early childhood memories, the ones where, even though they happened so long ago, you recall them more clearly than you remember most things? For David Quiroz, his happened when he was seven, in second grade, back in 1993. His PE teacher told their class, we're going to watch a movie today.
你知道那些非常鲜活的童年早期记忆吗？即使过了很久，你记得它们比记得大多数事情都要清晰。对于大卫·基罗斯（David Quiroz）来说，这件事发生在他七岁那年，1993年，上小学二年级的时候。他的体育老师告诉全班，我们今天要看一部电影。
And she rolled the AV cart with the TV and the VCR on it. She popped in a Blockbuster rental or whatever it was. She pressed Play. She turned off the lights and walked away. She made mention of the fact that she needed to go to the teacher's lounge to make copies-- I don't know of what. But she was just gone. And we were just there.
然后她推来了放着电视和录像机的视听推车。她塞进了一部在百视达租来的电影，或者类似的什么片子。她按下了播放键。她关了灯，然后走了。她提了一句要去教师休息室复印些什么——我不知道是什么。但她就是走了。而我们就被留在了那里。
Ahh. Haha!
啊。哈哈！
The movie? Leprechaun. Maybe you're familiar, but if you're not, Leprechaun is a 1993 horror film starring a young Jennifer Aniston. It's rated R. It's about a leprechaun who goes on a murderous rampage to try to hunt down his stolen pot of gold.
电影是什么？《鬼精》（Leprechaun）。也许你很熟悉，如果不熟悉的话，《鬼精》是一部1993年的恐怖片，由年轻的詹妮弗·安妮斯顿（Jennifer Aniston）主演。它被评为R级。讲的是一个鬼精为了寻找他被偷走的金罐子，进行了一场杀戮狂欢。
Try as they will, and try as they might, who steals me gold, won't live through the night. Hahaha!
无论怎么尝试，谁偷了我的金子，都活不过今晚。哈哈哈哈！
We're sitting there, watching the movie. And I remember immediately people being afraid and people being giddy with excitement at the same time. Where there was kids who were just like, oh, I've seen this. My older brother showed me this, and it's scary! And everyone else is just like, I don't know about this.
我们坐在那里看电影。我记得人们立刻感到了恐惧，同时又感到一阵兴奋。有些孩子说，噢，我看过这个。我哥哥给我看过，太可怕了！而其他人则说，我不确定这片子怎么样。
Which was against the rules.
这违反了学校规定。
David remembers thinking, what the hell is happening?
大卫记得自己当时在想，这到底发生了什么？
I'm going to suffocate.
我要窒息了。
Oh, I hated it. It was terrifying. I remember people crying. And everyone had this, you have to stay in your seats, and we're going to obey because an adult told us to.
噢，我讨厌它。太恐怖了。我记得有人在哭。每个人都在想，你必须坐在座位上，我们要听话，因为大人告诉我们要遵守纪律。
Here are some of the things that happen in this movie. There are scenes of the leprechaun biting off a face, also an ear. He snares people in bear traps. He snaps the neck of a bloody police officer, then rips that officer's eye from his corpse, only to shove said eye into his own gouged out eye socket.
这部电影里发生了一些事情。有鬼精咬掉人脸的场景，还有一个耳朵。他用捕兽夹困住人。他扭断了一个满身是血的警察的脖子，然后从尸体上挖出那名警察的眼睛，塞进了自己被挖出的眼眶里。
An eye for an eye, my dear.
以眼还眼，我亲爱的。
It's stupid and scary.
这又蠢又吓人。
Fuck you, Lucky Charms!
去你的，幸运饼干！
Oh, and also language. Again, these kids are in second grade, like seven years old.
噢，还有里面的语言。再说一次，这些孩子才二年级，大概七岁。
And I remember, especially in scenes where the leprechaun was attacking people--
我记得，特别是在鬼精攻击人的场景中——
Help! Please! Please! Help!
救命！拜托！拜托！救命！
--that there were kids who were holding their eyes to their desk or doing the heads up, seven up, where you put your head down. And there were kids who had their hands over their ears.
——有些孩子把脸埋在桌子上，或者做“抬头七”游戏，就是把头低下。还有些孩子用手捂住耳朵。
This was near Halloween. Kids remember the teacher saying she put the movie on to get everyone in the holiday spirit, which worked for some kids. David says some of them were into it. And that's where it got complicated.
当时快到万圣节了。孩子们记得老师说她放电影是为了让大家感受到节日气氛，这对一些孩子来说确实奏效了。大卫说其中一些孩子很喜欢。而问题也随之而来。
Because the kids who were putting their heads down at their desks and covering their ears were being ridiculed by the bully kids because, why are you scared? Why are you scared of this? This isn't scary. This is funny.
因为那些把头埋在桌上并捂住耳朵的孩子受到了霸凌小孩的嘲笑，他们说，你们怕什么？你们为什么要怕这个？这不可怕，这很有趣。
[CACKLES] Do you like the gold buckles on me shoes?
[狞笑] 你们喜欢我鞋子上的金扣子吗？
Well, I guess I should also point out-- I went to a school that was entirely Mexican-American, as I was. And the only reason I say that is because in Mexican-American culture, there is this cultural pressure to be tough.
好吧，我想我应该指出——我上的学校全都是墨西哥裔美国人，我也是其中之一。我这么说只是因为在墨西哥裔美国文化中，有一种要表现得强硬的文化压力。
Particularly in his neighborhood, David says. The place he grew up was basically all Mexican, all working class, but also had a reputation for being kind of a tough part of town.
特别是在他居住的社区，大卫说。他长大的地方基本上全是墨西哥人，都是工薪阶层，但也以“地段有点硬”而闻名。
And so, oftentimes, instances where siblings are helping to raise one another, I've seen some things. There was a number of kids in the class who were walking to school by themselves at six years old or seven years old. And we had some rough-ass kids. And those rough-ass kids had way different perspectives than the kids whose parents tried to keep scary things away from them. And so, half the class was enjoying the horror movie, and half the class was terrified and crying.
所以，很多时候，我见过兄弟姐妹互相扶持的情况，我见过一些事情。班上有不少孩子在六七岁时就自己走路去上学。我们班里有些很粗野的孩子。而那些孩子和父母试图让可怕的事情远离他们的孩子，有着完全不同的看法。所以，班里有一半孩子在享受这部恐怖片，而另一半则被吓坏了，正在哭泣。
At some point, the teacher came back into the room, saw that people were visibly crying-- saw that people were crying and were visibly upset and then admonished the kids for crying. She said, why are y'all crying? This is a holiday movie. And I was just like, all right. I beg to differ, but.
在某个时刻，老师回到房间，看到人们在哭——看到人们在哭泣并明显感到不安，然后斥责孩子们哭。她说，你们为什么要哭？这是一部节日电影。我当时就想，好吧。我对此持不同意见，但是。
And then, well, she's like, y'all need to toughen up, that kind of thing. And then, she said, OK, well, if you don't want to watch it, I don't want to teach. And so, you can sit outside. And sitting outside wasn't-- it was like sitting on the steps. And they were the outside main entrance steps to the school.
然后，她说，你们需要坚强点，大概这种意思。接着，她说，好吧，如果你们不想看，我也不想教了。所以，你们可以坐在外面。而坐在外面并不是——那就像坐在台阶上。那是学校外面的主入口台阶。
His teacher didn't want to speak to me for the story. David and about half a dozen of his classmates walked outside, stunned.
他的老师拒绝接受我的故事采访。大卫和大约半打同学走出了门，惊魂未定。
We were sitting on the steps, and no one was talking. No one was saying anything.
我们坐在台阶上，没有人说话。没有人说任何话。
Any trying to comfort each other or anything like that?
有试图安慰彼此之类的事情吗？
No, we were all suffering independently next to each other.
没有，我们各自坐在彼此旁边独自受苦。
When school was finally over, David's aunt picked him up like usual.
当学校终于放学时，大卫的姨妈像往常一样来接他。
And I told her, yeah, this thing happened at school. We saw something. And she was concerned because I couldn't even get the words out. I was just scared to talk about it, I guess.
我告诉她，是的，学校发生了这件事。我们看到了某种东西。她很担心，因为我连话都说不出来。我想我是害怕谈论它。
Which was really unlike him. David was a chatty, hyper verbal kid, the smart kid in class. So when he was suddenly unable to talk, she and David's mom knew something was wrong, but they didn't get why he was freaking out so bad about some movie about leprechauns.
这真的很不像他。大卫是一个健谈、话特别多、班上很聪明的孩子。所以当他突然说不出话时，她和他的妈妈知道出事了，但她们不明白为什么他会因为一部关于鬼精的电影吓成这样。
And so, my older cousins came home and were just like, no, that's a horror movie. No, they couldn't have shown that to the kids. There's no justification for that.
于是，我的表哥表姐们回家后说，不，那是恐怖片。不，他们不可能给孩子们看这个。这根本说不过去。
David's cousins, like a lot of older cousins, were kind of that weird mix between bodyguards and tormentors. Like, this is our nerd. No one messes with him but us. David's mom, Jovita, says that after the movie, David couldn't sleep alone for weeks.
大卫的表亲们，像许多年长的表亲一样，有点像是保镖和折磨者的混合体。比如，这是我们的书呆子。除了我们，谁也不许动他。大卫的母亲乔维塔（Jovita）说，在那部电影之后，大卫几周内都没法独自睡觉。
He didn't want to take a shower behind a closed curtain. I had to sit in the bathroom with him. Because he was old enough to shower by himself, but I had to sit in there, have the curtains semi-open, and say, I'm here, son. Go ahead. Especially when I had to wash his hair and his face, you know? When he washed it, if he closed his eyes, I had to make sure I held his hand.
他不想在拉着浴帘的情况下洗澡。我不得不坐在浴室里陪他。因为他已经大到可以自己洗澡了，但我不得不坐在那儿，把帘子拉开一半，说，我在呢，儿子。去洗吧。特别是当我要帮他洗头和洗脸时，你知道吗？当他洗脸闭上眼睛时，我必须确保抓住他的手。
David felt like any time his eyes were closed, he might open them and find a demon leprechaun attacking him. Jovita told me that after the movie, there was a way that fear just kind of wormed its way into the rest of David's life, like at the grocery store, Jovita told me. He was afraid to go down the Halloween aisle, didn't like seeing the masks or anything costumey. Jovita bought him a Batman nightlight. He'd never been afraid of the dark before.
大卫觉得只要闭上眼睛，他一睁开眼可能会发现一个恶魔鬼精正在攻击他。乔维塔告诉我，电影之后，这种恐惧就像钻进了大卫生活的其余部分，比如在杂货店，乔维塔告诉我。他不敢去万圣节区域，不喜欢看到面具或任何戏服之类的东西。乔维塔给他买了一个蝙蝠侠的小夜灯。他以前从来没怕过黑。
A lot of people have a movie like this when you're a kid, the movie you see way too young, after which you kind of can't get your life back. Sometimes it's The Exorcist or something. Or I heard from someone who could never recover after seeing a documentary about acid rain in second grade science class.
很多人在小时候都有过这样的电影，你在太小的时候看的电影，之后你的人生就仿佛回不到过去了一样。有时是《驱魔人》之类。或者我听说有人在二年级科学课上看了关于酸雨的纪录片后就再也没缓过来。
For me, it was The Piano, a period drama with Holly Hunter about frontiersmen in New Zealand in the 1800s. It's rated R for moments of, quote, "extremely graphic sexuality." Also, a guy chops off his wife's finger with an ax, which I will never not remember. I saw it when I was 10. I don't know why I didn't turn it off.
对我来说，那是《钢琴别恋》（The Piano），一部关于1800年代新西兰边境定居者的古装剧。它因包含所谓的“极其露骨的性行为”片段被评为R级。此外，剧中一个男人用斧头砍掉了他妻子的手指，我永远忘不了这一幕。我10岁时看到的。我不知道为什么我没关掉它。
For what it's worth, I'm also Latina. Toughness was a point of pride in my family, too. But the big difference between David and me is that I saw that movie, and it was over. I didn't talk about it. I did everything I could to shut it out. That wasn't possible for David. Because in David's case, over 200 kids in his school went through this mandatory horror together, all at once.
值得一提的是，我也是拉丁裔。坚强在我的家庭里也是一种荣誉。但我和大卫最大的区别在于，我看了那部电影，然后就结束了。我没有谈论它。我尽我所能把它关在脑后。这对大卫来说是不可能的。因为在大卫的案例中，他学校里有200多个孩子同时经历了这种强制性的恐怖教育。
Four teachers played the movie to a bunch of classes, second graders up through fifth graders. Parents all started calling each other about it and calling the school. So David couldn't put it away because it was all anyone would talk about. It became the thing that happened that year.
四位老师给一群孩子放了这部电影，从二年级一直到五年级。家长们开始互相打电话谈论这件事，并打电话给学校。所以大卫无法把这件事抛在脑后，因为它成了每个人都在谈论的话题。它成了那一年发生的大事。
And if you think this is the point where adults come in and make things better, it's not. Because what happened instead was what happens a lot of the time when you're a kid and adults swoop in to try to solve something, which is, they sometimes make it so much worse.
如果你认为这是大人们介入让事情好转的节点，那你就错了。因为相反，当你在小时候，大人们蜂拥而至试图解决某个问题时，往往会发生一种情况，那就是，他们有时会把事情搞得更糟。
This is Fox News, 1230.
这是福克斯新闻，1230。
Houston Elementary School teachers are under fire for showing an R-rated movie to students.
休斯顿的一所小学教师因给学生放R级电影而受到猛烈抨击。
Someone's mom called the news.
某个学生的妈妈打了新闻热线。
The Leprechaun controversy started at Browning Elementary School--
鬼精争议始于布朗宁小学——
More than 200 Browning students--
超过200名布朗宁的学生——
Leprechaun is a violent tale of a murderous elf.
《鬼精》是一个关于杀人精灵的暴力故事。
I think it was nasty.
我认为这很恶心。
What do you mean, nasty?
你说的恶心是什么意思？
There was nasty parts and dirty words.
里面有恶心的部分和下流的词汇。
Parents and relatives are outraged.
家长和亲属感到愤怒。
Horrible!
太可怕了！
I don't think it's something that should have been done in school. I think it should have been done at home.
我不认为这是学校应该做的事情。我认为这应该在家里完成。
Debra, help me with the terminology here. Is Browning on that list of what they call troubled or unacceptable schools or whatever?
黛布拉（Debra），帮我解释一下术语。布朗宁是在那些所谓的“有问题”或“不可接受”的学校名单上吗？
David's mom happens to be one of those moms who kept the news on all the time.
大卫的妈妈恰好是那种一直开着电视的母亲。
And whenever the local Houston newscasters would talk about it, they would show a clip of the movie in the background. So it would be a voiceover over stock footage of The Leprechaun.
每当当地休斯顿的新闻主播谈论这件事时，他们就会在背景中播放电影片段。所以声音是在《鬼精》的画面上进行旁白。
And hurt them he does in some rather graphic ways.
他以相当残忍的方式伤害了他们。
Burn in hell, you little green [BLEEP].
下地狱去吧，你这绿色的小[消音]。
So now, David would be at home, sitting at the kitchen table, just doing his homework, and suddenly, the leprechaun's demented visage would spring into sight out of nowhere, terrifying him anew each time.
所以现在，大卫在家里，坐在厨房桌旁做作业，突然，鬼精那张疯癫的面孔就会毫无预兆地蹦出来，每次都让他感到新的恐惧。
This old lep, he played one!
这个老鬼精，他玩了一个！
Like in that news clip, this old lep, he played one, he played pogo on his lung. What's happening in this clip is the leprechaun is jumping on a pogo stick on top of a man's chest, somehow impaling him with each jump, blood spurting everywhere. This was on the news all the time. I have 27 different clips I could find. And with every story, the footage.
就像那个新闻片段里说的，这个老鬼精，他玩了一个，他在人的肺上玩跳跳杆。这段视频中发生的是，鬼精踩在人的胸口上玩跳跳杆，每一次跳跃都以某种方式刺穿了他，鲜血四溅。这在新闻上一直播。我能找到27个不同的片段。每一次报道，都伴随着这些画面。
And they say this movie should not have been shown at all.
他们说这部电影根本就不应该播放。
I want me gold coin! Ahh!
我要我的金币！啊！
Jovita would scramble to cover David's eyes and mute, but she couldn't always get there fast enough. 330 parents signed a petition asking that the school fire the teachers. For weeks, reporters were at the school.
乔维塔会手忙脚乱地盖住大卫的眼睛并调成静音，但她并不总能及时赶到。330名家长签署请愿书，要求学校开除这些老师。几周来，记者们一直守在学校。
And the two factions of kids, the ones who were terrified by the movie and the ones who thought those kids were losers, basically ended up making their case on TV, making the divide between the scared kids and the brave kids even wider and so public. And you know who came off really well? The brave kids.
孩子们分为两派，被电影吓坏的一派，和认为那些孩子是窝囊废的一派，基本上都在电视上发表意见，让害怕的孩子和勇敢的孩子之间的鸿沟变得更深、更公开。你知道谁表现得很好吗？那些勇敢的孩子。
But other children we talked with say it was no big deal. Did you think the movie was too scary?
但我们采访的其他孩子说这没什么大不了的。你觉得电影太吓人了吗？
A little bit.
有一点点。
Were you surprised to be seeing a movie like this in class?
你对在课堂上看到这样的电影感到惊讶吗？
No.
没有。
Thanks a lot, Enrique Lopez. But a few kids did talk about how scared they were, the one everyone remembers.
多谢了，恩里克·洛佩兹（Enrique Lopez）。但有几个孩子确实谈到了他们有多害怕，那是每个人都记得的一位。
Little Chastity walked out of class during the movie.
小查斯蒂（Chastity）在电影放映时走出了教室。
I saw half of it. And the movie-- and the person came out, and it was ugly.
我看了半部。电影里——那个人出来的时候，真丑。
So the movie scared you?
所以电影吓到你了？
Yes.
是的。
Chastity was one of the kids on the steps with David that day. It was different for her, though. She told me, it wasn't so much the movie itself that she was afraid of.
查斯蒂那天和戴维一起坐在台阶上。但对她来说情况有所不同。她告诉我，她害怕的不仅仅是电影本身。
It was more scared for my soul, I guess. This was like the height of the Satanic panic. And my parents were holy roller people. And I had been told as a child my whole life, Satan could get to you from things like movies or bad books.
我想我更害怕的是我的灵魂。这是撒旦恐慌的高峰期。我的父母是那种非常虔诚的信徒。我从小就被告知，撒旦可以通过电影或坏书之类的东西进入你的生活。
Chastity only watched a couple of minutes of the movie before she'd booked it out of the classroom. Less than five, she was sure. Was that enough for Satan?
查斯蒂只看了几分钟电影就逃出了教室。她很确定不到五分钟。这对撒旦来说够了吗？
I mean, I was literally frightened that I had, in some way, participated enough to where the devil would come and invade my soul.
我是说，我真的害怕自己以某种方式参与得太多，以至于魔鬼会进来侵犯我的灵魂。
Not the sort of kid who wants to end up on TV. But one afternoon, reporters are in front of the school, interviewing her mom, who is not just outraged, but also the mom talking on the news the most about her outrage. And Chastity is just standing there next to her, feeling embarrassed.
她不是那种想上电视的孩子。但一天下午，记者们在学校门前采访她的母亲，母亲不仅愤怒，而且是新闻中最常谈论这种愤怒的妈妈。查斯蒂站在她旁边，感到很尴尬。
And I felt like everybody was looking at me. And people were kind of laughing and stuff. And I kind of stood out like a sore thumb anyways, because I was the only--
我觉得每个人都在看我。人们在嘲笑什么的。无论如何，我像秃子头上的虱子一样显眼，因为我是唯一一个——
Chastity, by the way, was the only white kid in her class.
顺便说一句，查斯蒂是班里唯一的白人孩子。
Pale with blond hair and blue eyes. So I felt like I couldn't just disappear, blend in, even if I wanted to. But I remember talking to the reporters and I just remember them asking, how did it make you feel? Or how was the movie? And I just said, it was scary.
皮肤白皙，金发蓝眼。所以我感觉自己没法躲藏或融合，即使我想。但我记得记者问我，这让你感觉如何？或者电影怎么样？我就说，那很吓人。
The kids at school ran with that. She'd pass kids in the hall, and they'd yell, it was scary, behind her. And Chastity had never been one of the coolest kids to begin with.
学校里的孩子跟着起哄。她在走廊里走过，孩子们就会在后面大喊“那很吓人”。查斯蒂本来就不是那种最酷的孩子。
I had a lot of friends, and most people were nice to me, but I also was very insecure. I had a lot of issues at home. And then just, too, physically, how different I was than everybody else, and then with this whole situation, it just brought more attention to me, I felt like. And I felt like I was bullied more. I cried about it for sure.
我有很多朋友，大多数人对我很好，但我也很自卑。我在家里有很多问题。再加上，在生理上，我和其他人有多么不同，现在再加上这一整件事，我感觉它让我受到了更多的关注。我觉得我被霸凌得更厉害了。我确实为这件事哭过。
So it's like the little phrase that has gone down in infamy, I guess. She was like, it was scary. And yeah.
所以这就是那个变得声名狼藉的小短句。她说，那很吓人。是的。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
Because I am 35 now, and I will still, when I run into people from elementary school or someone gets in contact with me on social media, they'll still say the whole, it was scary. And it's like, it kind of feels like sometimes if people don't even remember the whole situation, they remember the it was scary part. And that was the sound bite, I guess, because whenever they ran out of material to kind of make fun of me with, it would revert back to that.
因为我今年35岁了，当我碰到小学同学，或者有人在社交媒体上联系我时，他们还是会说那个，“那很吓人”。感觉就像有时即使人们记不住整个情况，他们也会记住“那很吓人”那部分。我想那成了标志性片段，因为每当他们找不到素材来取笑我时，就会回到那个话题。
Because of it was scary and the fact that her mom was so vocal on the news, Chastity says kids and teachers blamed her for squealing to her mom and for bringing all this chaos and negative attention to the school. When Chastity looks back on all this, there's a whole list of adults who put her in this situation-- her mom, a TV reporter who made her the poster child for the losers, her parents and church, who told her the devil would come after her if she saw a movie like this, and of course, her teacher, who showed her the movie.
因为“那很吓人”这句话，加上她妈妈在新闻上那么高调，查斯蒂说孩子和老师都怪她向妈妈告状，给学校带来了混乱和负面关注。当查斯蒂回顾这一切时，有一长串的大人把她置于这种境地——她的妈妈，把她塑造成失败者海报女孩的电视记者，告诉她如果看了那样的电影魔鬼就会来找她的父母和教会，当然，还有给她放电影的老师。
The four teachers who'd shown the movie were all removed from the school. Two were substitutes who were taken off the list of subs the school would call. The two full-time teachers were suspended for 10 days and then reassigned to other schools in the district, including David and Chastity's teacher.
四位放映电影的老师都被从学校除名了。两名代课老师被从学校呼叫的代课名单中删除。两名全职教师被停职10天，然后重新分配到该区的其他学校，其中包括大卫和查斯蒂的老师。
The teachers apologized. David and Chastity's teacher said she owned the movie, but didn't know what was on it. That's the closest thing I found to an explanation for all this.
老师们道歉了。大卫和查斯蒂的老师说她拥有这部电影，但不知道里面具体是什么内容。这是我找到的对这一切最接近的解释。
There was one thing the adults at school did to try to more directly help the kids, which also went a little weird. David remembers a woman coming to his class. She told them she was a grief counselor.
学校大人们做了一件事试图更直接地帮助孩子，但也搞得很奇怪。大卫记得一个女人来到他的班上。她告诉他们她是心理辅导员。
There was an introduction that said, hi, I'm here to talk about things. If you have any fears or concerns, that's exactly what I'm here for.
有一个开场白说，嗨，我来这里是为了谈论一些事情。如果你有任何恐惧或担忧，这就是我在这里的原因。
Which David thought, that sounds OK. I do have fears and concerns. But when she started the session, he didn't like how she started.
大卫觉得，这听起来不错。我确实有恐惧和担忧。但当她开始辅导时，他不喜欢她的开始方式。
If anyone would like to talk about what they saw in Leprechaun, please come to the nurse's office now or whatever office they had us in. And you had to raise your hand after they asked.
如果有谁想谈谈在《鬼精》里看到的，请现在去医务室，或者他们安排给我们的办公室。他们问完后你必须举手。
So basically, they were just like, is anyone here still afraid of The Leprechaun thing? Raise your hand if so.
所以基本上，他们就是说，这里还有谁害怕《鬼精》的事？如果害怕就举手。
What did you do? Do you raise your hand, or did you--
你怎么做？你是举手，还是——
Yes. We literally stood up and walked to the nurse's office as a group, a group of sad kids. And all the asshole kids were just making fun of everyone who stood up or raised their hand, which was like, you're a wuss. You wet the bed. You have bad dreams. You suck, that kind of thing.
是的。我们真的作为一群伤心的孩子站起来，一起走向医务室。所有那些混蛋孩子都在嘲笑每一个站起来或举手的人，说你是软蛋。你尿床。你做噩梦。你真烂，诸如此类的。
Let me just point out the structural flaw at this plan. Let's ask the kids who are already being teased to self-identify as weenies in front of their peers and get marched away as a group. Anyway, the grief counselor sat the sad kids down in their sad little group.
让我指出这个计划的结构性缺陷。让我们要求那些本就受到戏弄的孩子在同龄人面前自认为是软蛋，然后被当作一群人带走。总之，心理辅导员让伤心的孩子们坐进他们可悲的小圈子里。
She starts asking us questions. And the questions are, presumably, basic grief counselor questions. What's your name? Do you feel safe at home? What's your home life like?
她开始问我们问题。这些问题，据推测，是基本的心理辅导问题。你叫什么名字？你在家里感到安全吗？你的家庭生活是什么样的？
Questions appropriate for kids who are experiencing loss or abuse or neglect, not necessarily Leprechaun specific. And then time ran out, and that was it, which definitely wasn't worth the public shaming. So when she came to class the next time, a lot of the kids who'd come to the first session dropped out. David, for whatever reason, went again.
这些问题适合那些正在经历丧失亲人、虐待或忽视的孩子，而不一定是针对《鬼精》的。然后时间到了，这就是一切，这绝对不值得那种公众羞辱。所以当她下次来班上时，很多参加了第一次会议的孩子退出了。大卫，不管什么原因，又去了。
And so, the grief counselor, again, she just starts asking basic questions about who you are and if you feel safe. And I remember raising my hand and being like, are we going to talk about the leprechaun? Are we going to talk about how to kill this thing?
于是，心理辅导员又开始问关于你是谁以及你是否感到安全的基本问题。我记得我举手说，我们要谈论那个鬼精吗？我们要谈论怎么杀掉那东西吗？
Because in my mind, it was a real fear. The six-year-old me was like, this is bullshit. This counselor is not worth a damn. She's not giving us practical advice. Why are we wasting time talking about this? We need to focus on killing the fucking leprechaun.
因为在我的脑海里，这是一种真实的恐惧。六岁的我觉得，这太扯了。这个辅导员根本没用。她没给我们实际的建议。我们为什么要浪费时间谈论这个？我们需要集中精力杀掉那个该死的鬼精。
And I remember asking the grief counselor, so if the leprechaun comes, should we just be carrying change with us? Do I need to carry gold to exchange my life? Because I think there's a scene in the movie where they distract the leprechaun by throwing coins in the air. I guess the idea was that if they saw coins, they had to count them or pick them up or something.
我记得我问心理辅导员，所以如果鬼精来了，我们应该随身带着零钱吗？我需要带金子来交换生命吗？因为我想电影里有一个场景，他们通过把硬币扔到空中来分散鬼精的注意力。我想这意思大概是，如果它们看到硬币，就得去数或者捡起来之类的。
And they were throwing shoes because the leprechaun was a cobbler, and he needed to clean shoes. But it was those types of questions. Do I need holy water? For real, I need somebody who's educated in this who's seen the movie and can tell me the actual practical recipe to killing a leprechaun.
他们还扔鞋子，因为鬼精是个鞋匠，需要清理鞋子。但就是这类问题。我需要圣水吗？我是说真的，我需要一个受过教育、看过电影的人能告诉我杀掉鬼精的实际方法。
What did she say?
她说什么？
I remember her being kind of taken aback by the questions and just giving the same kind of stock answer of, this isn't real. This isn't something you should have to worry about, which is not helpful. It felt more like, oh, let's send her to the poor Brown school and make sure the kids are all right.
我记得她被这些问题搞得有些吃惊，只是给了同样的标准答案，说这不真实。这不是你应该担心的事，这毫无帮助。感觉更像是，噢，让我们派她去那所贫穷的布朗学校，确保孩子们没事就行了。
David just remembers feeling like the message he was getting from adults kept being like, the problem isn't the movie. The problem is your reaction. There's no reason to be so scared. David didn't agree. Again, he was a really bright kid in a class with other bright kids.
大卫只记得感觉大人们传达的信息一直都是，问题不在于电影。问题在于你的反应。没理由这么害怕。大卫不同意。再说一遍，他是一个非常聪明的孩子，班上也有其他聪明的孩子。
And so, people were more able to express, yo, I don't have anything at home that I'm really worried about. I'm just really worried about the leprechaun. Or I'm afraid of the dark. Or one girl wet the bed as a result of it, which is sad and true.
因此，人们更能表达，嘿，我在家里没什么可担心的。我只是真的很担心鬼精。或者我怕黑。或者有个女孩因此尿床了，这既悲伤又真实。
How do you know that?
你怎么知道的？
Because we had to disclose these things in this fucking group session to this goddamn grief counselor.
因为我们不得不在这个该死的团体辅导中向这个该死的心理辅导员透露这些事情。
So the grief counselor was like, has anyone in here wet the bed, and someone had to raise their hand?
所以心理辅导员问，这里有人尿床过吗，有人不得不举手？
Oh, yeah, somebody had to opt into that, right? And it was a little girl in my class.
噢，是的，有人不得不选择这样做，对吧？那是我班上的一个小女孩。
You remember her name?
你记得她的名字吗？
[BLEEP] Lopez. [LAUGHS] Please bleep that.
[消音] 洛佩兹。[笑] 请消音那个。
I'll bleep it. I'll bleep it.
我会消音的。我会消音。
Oh, David, so considerate all these years later. You know who wasn't so discreet? [BLEEP] Lopez's mom. She told the news.
噢，大卫，多年以后还是这么体贴。你知道谁没那么谨慎吗？[消音] 洛佩兹的妈妈。她告诉了新闻。
She's urinating in her bed, and she doesn't want to sleep alone. She's just-- I just have a lot of problems with her right now.
她在床上尿尿，而且她不想一个人睡。她只是——我现在在处理她很多问题。
Parents-- am I right?
家长们——我说的对吧？
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, teenagers left in a room with other teenagers at church. What could possibly go wrong there? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，青少年在教会里和其他青少年一起被留在房间里。那里可能会出什么错呢？一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, the kids' table, stories of what happens when the kids are on their own. The grown-ups have left the room, and the kids have to figure things out by themselves.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“儿童餐”，讲述当孩子们独自一人时发生的故事。大人们离开了房间，孩子们必须自己解决问题。
We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, "Classified Dad." This story is about what happens when an adult really is never around at all for a long time and the strange consequences and desires that can come out of that. Chris Benderev explains.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“机密老爸”。这个故事讲述的是当一个成年人真的很长一段时间不在身边时，会产生什么样的奇怪后果和欲望。克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）解释。
In 2018, Georgie Codd was on a cruise with her mom. And the day this all started was not as fun as she'd imagined. Their ship had been scheduled to dock at the picturesque Shetland Islands off the northern coast of Scotland, but instead, because of bad weather, the boat had docked in an unremarkable industrial Scottish town.
2018年，乔治·科德（Georgie Codd）正和她妈妈一起坐游轮。事情开始的那天并不像她想象的那样有趣。他们的船原定停靠在苏格兰北海岸风景如画的设得兰群岛，但由于天气恶劣，船停靠在一个平淡无奇的苏格兰工业城镇。
We were rerouted to a port called invergordon, which possibly has a lot going for it, but I'd imagined that we'd be in Shetland, having this wonderful time, looking at tiny horses-- because Shetland ponies. And instead, we went to a very dreary museum, looking at a reproduction stethoscope from 1965. And then Peter, our friend Peter popped up.
我们被改道到一个叫因弗戈登的港口，那里可能有很多优点，但我本来想象我们会在设得兰群岛，度过一段美好的时光，看着小马——因为有设得兰矮种马。结果我们去了一个非常沉闷的博物馆，看了一个1965年的听诊器复制品。然后彼得（Peter），我们的朋友彼得出现了。
Peter was a 70-year-old man from Wales who Georgie and her mom had met in the cruise ship's dining hall a few days earlier. He'd told them corny jokes and a lot of stories from his days as a firefighter. They liked him. And now, in the museum, he invited the two of them to go get coffee.
彼得是一位来自威尔士的70岁老人，乔治和她妈妈几天前在游轮的餐厅里认识了他。他给她们讲了些俗气的笑话和许多他当消防员时的故事。她们很喜欢他。现在在博物馆，他邀请她们俩去喝咖啡。
We found this community cafe, and the three of us sat down on a table, which had an empty seat. And about two, three minutes later, a woman came up who none of us had met before, but was also on the cruise ship. And she asked us, could she sit and join us on the table?
我们找到了这个社区咖啡馆，我们三个人坐在一张桌子旁，旁边有一个空位。大约两三分钟后，一个我们都不认识的女人走了过来，她也是游轮上的乘客。她问我们，能不能坐下来和我们拼桌？
And without skipping a beat, Peter said, oh, I was just telling my wife and daughter it'd be lovely to have some company. And she sat down, none the wiser. My mum, I think, groaned, possibly rolled her eyes. And then he spotted my mum's reaction to what he'd said, and he corrected himself. Oh, ex-wife, ex-wife. We liked to go on holiday still for Georgina to keep the family together.
彼得毫不犹豫地说，噢，我刚才正告诉我的妻子和女儿，有个人陪伴真好。她坐了下来，什么都不知道。我想我妈妈呻吟了一声，可能还翻了个白眼。然后他注意到了我妈妈对他所说的话的反应，于是他纠正自己。噢，前妻，前妻。我们喜欢去度假，还是为了乔治娜（Georgina）一家团聚。
Georgie's mom mostly sat out this practical joke. Georgie, meanwhile, tried to gauge whether Peter was really going to keep this up. He was.
乔治的妈妈大多时候没参与这个恶作剧。与此同时，乔治试图评估彼得是否真的要一直演下去。他会的。
He was saying things like, oh, Georgina's very clever. She's a writer. She's published a book. She did really well at school.
他说，噢，乔治娜很聪明。她是个作家。她出版过书。她在学校表现很好。
All true, by the way. Georgie decided to play along.
顺便说一句，都是真的。乔治决定配合他。
Oh, Pops works in the fire service, you know. He's a retired firefighter. He used to go up and down the town in Swansea, asking the ladies to get on his fire truck. And I have no doubt the woman thought we were a very strange family, but she seemed to believe that we were a family.
噢，老爸在消防局工作，你知道的。他是个退休消防员。他以前经常在斯旺西镇上下走动，让女士们上他的消防车。我毫无疑问，那个女人认为我们是一个非常奇怪的家庭，但她似乎相信我们确实是一家子。
Eventually, Peter, Georgie, and her mom said goodbye to the woman and left. Out on the street, they laughed, proud of pulling off this stupid little caper. As they walked back to the ship, Peter mentioned to Georgie--
最终，彼得、乔治和她妈妈跟那个女人道别离开了。走在街上，她们大笑起来，为自己完成了这个愚蠢的小骗局而自豪。当她们走回游轮时，彼得对乔治提到——
I always wondered what it would be like to have a daughter. And I thought immediately, wow, I've always wondered what it would be like to have a dad.
我一直想知道有一个女儿是什么感觉。我立刻想到，哇，我一直想知道有一个爸爸是什么感觉。
Georgie's dad wasn't with her on this cruise because he wasn't in her life, never had been, left before Georgie was even born. When she was 25, she found out where he lived and arranged a visit. She packed her bags and was on her way to the station when she got a call from her uncle telling her that her dad had died. He'd had health issues. The closest she got to him was at the funeral.
乔治的爸爸没有和她一起坐这艘游轮，因为他不在她的生活中，从来没在过，在乔治出生前就离开了。25岁时，她打听到了他住的地方并安排了一次拜访。她收拾好行李，正要去车站时，接到了叔叔打来的电话，说她爸爸去世了。他有健康问题。她离他最近的一次就是在葬礼上。
So she'd never had a father figure in her life until in a really small, silly way, those 15 minutes in the cafe with Peter. It'd been such an odd thing, but it felt so good and so unusual. And she just wanted to see, could that be a relationship that she'd have in her life? An older man to give advice and make dad jokes and be proud.
所以她生命中从来没有过父亲形象，直到在那个咖啡馆里，以一种非常微小、愚蠢的方式，与彼得呆了15分钟。这真是一件奇怪的事情，但感觉非常好，也非常独特。她只是想看看，这能成为她生活中可能拥有的关系吗？一个能提供建议、讲爸爸笑话并感到自豪的年长男人。
It's like he lit a little spark or something. I felt very elated. It seemed like a little door had opened or I'd glimpsed something.
就像他点燃了一点火花什么的。我感到非常兴奋。这看起来像是打开了一扇小门，或者我瞥见了什么。
What would you say that was?
你会说那是什么？
Hmm. I think it was a need to feel acceptable and lovable by men without a hidden agenda?
嗯。我觉得那是一种需要感觉到被男性接受和可爱，且没有隐藏目的的需求？
This is sort of a big thing to discover on a sightseeing trip to Invergordon, that she wanted a dad's love, but it stuck with her. She'd enjoyed Peter's improvisation, but that wasn't exactly what she was after. Then Georgie got an idea. And you should know, Georgie is the type of person who gets very creative when she tries to solve a problem. She once worked in a funeral parlor to deal with her fear of death, took scuba diving lessons because she was scared of fish.
在因弗戈登观光旅行中发现自己想要爸爸的爱，这是一件大事，但它深深地留在了她心里。她很享受彼得的即兴表演，但这并不是她真正追求的。然后乔治有了个主意。你应该知道，乔治是个在试图解决问题时非常有创意的人。她曾经在殡仪馆工作以克服对死亡的恐惧，因为怕鱼而去学了潜水。
And so she made an ad for a dad, a classified ad. It said she was looking for someone to act as a father figure, nothing sexual. She could be reached at [email protected] . Georgie figured a lot of the men who could be her father still read actual newspapers and magazines.
于是她登了一个爸爸的广告，一个分类广告。上面说她正在寻找一个人担任父亲的角色，没有性暗示。可以通过 [email protected] 联系她。乔治觉得很多可能成为她父亲的男人仍然读报纸和杂志。
So I started with a magazine called New Scientist because I thought I'd quite like a dad who knows science. And I decided for the advert to run just after Christmas because all the dad type folks would have got subscriptions for their Christmas present, so the numbers would be quite high--
所以我从一本叫《新科学家》（New Scientist）的杂志开始，因为我觉得我很想要一个懂科学的爸爸。我决定让广告在圣诞节后刊登，因为所有爸爸类型的人都会把订阅当作圣诞礼物，所以数量会很高——
That's quite sensible. That's very strategic.
这相当明智。非常有战略眼光。
Oh, I was, yeah, very strategic, very strategic.
噢，我是的，非常战略，非常战略。
As you might expect, she heard from a lot of creepy older guys. But they weren't all like that. Many people saw the ad for what it was and seemed genuinely interested. She emailed with a bunch of them, in particular, this one guy, Clive. He was in his 60s, had had kids from multiple marriages, was estranged from one of his children, something he seemed sad about. Georgie and Clive emailed for weeks, and then they started talking on the phone, too.
正如你可能预料的那样，她收到很多令人毛骨悚然的老男人的回信。但并非所有人都这样。许多人看到了广告的本质，并似乎真诚地感兴趣。她和其中不少人互发电子邮件，特别是这个叫克莱夫（Clive）的家伙。他60多岁，有过多次婚姻，还有孩子，与其中一个孩子疏远，这件事似乎让他很伤感。乔治和克莱夫通过邮件交流了几个星期，然后也开始通电话。
I mean, the first time on the phone, we both acknowledged the awkwardness of it, which was a great icebreaker and a green flag for me.
我是说，第一次打电话时，我们都承认了这种尴尬，这对我来说是一个很好的破冰和绿色信号。
Clive stood out from all the other fake dads that she'd e-mailed with.
克莱夫从她互发邮件的所有其他假爸爸中脱颖而出。
Some of these guys, they were just waxing lyrical about life and the universe and everything. But Clive was very engaged and remembered details that I told him, showed a real interest in me and my life. And I was interested in him and his life. And he was open about struggles that he'd had with mental health and alcohol. And we would easily be on the phone for 90 minutes, two hours. I think we clicked. We just clicked.
有些人只是在抒情地谈论生活、宇宙和万物。但克莱夫非常专注，记住了我告诉他的细节，对我以及我的生活表现出了真正的兴趣。我也对他的生活感兴趣。他对于自己在心理健康和酗酒方面的挣扎很坦诚。我们很容易就能通上90分钟、两个小时的电话。我想我们很投缘。我们就是投缘。
They talked about kids. Georgie was wondering if she should have them. And they talked politics-- more than she liked, even though their politics were the same.
他们谈到了孩子。乔治想知道她是否应该要孩子。他们谈论了政治——比她喜欢的还要多，尽管他们的政治观点是一样的。
Brexit. Brexit would come up so often. I guess, much like a daughter might do to their dad, which is like, ugh, I mean, can we just talk-- let's just talk about something else. Let's talk about something else. Shall I have babies or not? Come on, Clive. Tell me.
脱欧。脱欧话题经常出现。我猜，就像女儿对待爸爸那样，就是，呃，我是说，我们能不能谈——咱们聊点别的吧。聊点别的吧。我该不该生孩子？拜托，克莱夫。告诉我。
They never met face to face, but they talk on the phone maybe every month or so for a year and a half.
他们从未面对面见过，但他们大约每月通一次电话，持续了一年半。
It was going really well. After a while, though, things shifted a little bit. And we had this phone call. And towards the end of the call, he said that he had been drinking. And he started telling me that he loved me. And why wouldn't I call more regularly? He would love it if I would just call more regularly.
进展很顺利。然而过了一段时间，情况发生了一点变化。我们通了那个电话。在通话结束时，他说他喝醉了。他开始告诉我他爱我。为什么我不更经常地打电话？如果我能经常打电话，他会很高兴的。
And I felt cornered. And it wasn't anything like the tone of conversation we'd had for all those months up to that point. And I got scared. And I wrapped it up. And I emailed him that I didn't feel able to be in that relationship anymore, having heard what he'd said in that call.
我感到被逼到了墙角。那和我那些月来一直进行的谈话基调完全不同。我感到害怕。我挂断了。我给他发邮件说，在听到他在那通电话里说的话后，我不再觉得自己能维持那种关系了。
What did it do to you that 18 months into what seemed like a kind of successful fake dad situation, that he had actually seen it romantically?
在你所谓的“成功的假爸爸关系”进行了18个月后，他实际上从浪漫的角度来看待这件事，这对你有什么影响？
Well, it's interesting that you say romantic because, actually, it didn't feel like he was being romantic. Even though he was saying I love you, and I-- I didn't feel like he wanted to get in bed with me or anything. It just felt like he so craved, he was so craving the company.
嗯，你说浪漫很有意思，因为实际上，他感觉并不像是在搞浪漫。尽管他说我爱你，我——我并不觉得他想跟我上床什么的。只是觉得他太渴望了，他太渴望陪伴了。
Which is to say, she'd gotten exactly what she'd asked for-- a relationship like what a lot of people have with their parents, who, understandably, want more phone calls and time and attention.
也就是说，她得到了她所要求的——一种很多人与父母拥有的关系，他们理所当然地想要更多的电话和时间和关注。
And I couldn't be there. I couldn't call all the time. And I bailed. I think I got scared and went into hiding. I still feel extremely guilty and sad about that.
而我无法做到。我无法一直打电话。我逃跑了。我想我害怕了，躲了起来。对此我仍然感到极其愧疚和悲伤。
It's been six months since she emailed Clive, which, by the way, is not his real name. She couldn't bring herself to look in the inbox again until our interview. Still hasn't written back. Georgie is still in touch with the guy on the boat, the one who gave her the idea in the first place, Peter.
距离她给克莱夫发邮件已经六个月了，顺便说一句，那不是他的真名。直到我们的采访，她都没法让自己再看一眼收件箱。至今还没写回信。乔治仍然和船上的那个家伙保持联系，就是最初给她这个主意的人，彼得。
They talk now and then, are friendly. A while back, he mailed her a box of cakes when she was feeling down. And by the way, when she told him about the ad, he was horrified and worried. You're going to get murdered, he told her, just like a real dad would say.
他们现在偶尔聊天，关系友好。不久前，当她心情低落时，他给她寄了一盒蛋糕。顺便说一句，当她告诉他这个广告时，他感到震惊和担心。你会被害死的，他告诉她，就像真正的爸爸会说的那样。
Chris Benderev is a producer here at our show.
克里斯·本德雷夫是我们节目的制作人。
Act Three, "Stations of the Double Cross." So our show today is about kids trying to make sense of what happens when grown-ups are not around. And in this act, it's religious kids and the mischief they get into, even when they're trying to do right by God. Michelle Navarro attended a church retreat when she was in middle school. She has changed the names in this story.
第三幕，“双重背叛的车站”。所以我们今天的节目是关于孩子们试图理解当大人们不在场时会发生什么。在这一幕里，是宗教的孩子和他们参与的恶作剧，即使当他们试图做上帝认为正确的事情时。米歇尔·纳瓦罗（Michelle Navarro）在初中时参加过一次教会务虚会。她改变了这个故事中的名字。
I'd been hearing about the retreat for years. It happened every Easter at my local Catholic parish on the southwest side of Chicago. And at 13, when I was finally old enough, I thought I should go. I always noticed the effect that chanting prayers and rosaries had on the adults in my family. It was the only place I saw their faces fully rested, at peace, and wondered, why didn't I feel any of it? I was standing in between them, but I was an outsider.
我多年来一直听说这个务虚会。它每年复活节都在我芝加哥西南部的当地天主教教区举行。13岁时，当我终于到了足够的年龄，我想我应该去。我总是注意到诵经祈祷和念玫瑰经对家里大人们的影响。那是我唯一看到他们脸上完全得到休息、平静的地方，我心想，为什么我什么都没感觉到？我就站在他们中间，但我是一个局外人。
Don't get me wrong. I was a good kid, got good grades, spent a lot of time in libraries and book sections of thrift stores, went to catechism classes and mass every week. But Catholicism, I couldn't make any sense of it, and I really wanted to. This four-day retreat, it was run by the youth group at the parish, a group of teens from my neighborhood whose mission was to get other teens involved with the church. They hyped it up to us.
别误会。我是一个好孩子，成绩好，花很多时间在图书馆和旧货店的书籍区，每周都去参加教理班和弥撒。但天主教，我根本搞不懂，而且我真的很想搞懂。这个为期四天的务虚会是由教区的青年组举办的，一群来自我邻里的青少年，他们的使命是让其他青少年参与教会。他们向我们大肆宣传。
And the thing they said about it that really got my attention was that every year, during this retreat, there was a moment, a moment in the Catholic school gym basement where they found Jesus, felt his unconditional love. They describe this moment as warm and right and that it was when they knew they wanted to serve him.
关于它，真正吸引我注意的一点是，每年在务虚会期间，都会有一个时刻，在天主教学校的健身房地下室里，他们发现了耶稣，感受到了他无条件的爱。他们形容这个时刻是温暖而正确的，那是他们知道自己想侍奉他的时候。
They called it a newfound love, a newfound purpose, a change in perspective, which is what I felt I needed exactly. I had been waiting around for a revelation, an epiphany, and thought that this retreat is where I could feel it. So I signed up.
他们称之为一种新发现的爱，一种新发现的目的，一种观点的改变，这正是我认为我需要的。我一直等着神的启示，顿悟，我想这个务虚会就是我可以感觉到它的地方。于是我报名了。
The second day of the retreat was Good Friday, and they took us, a herd of 13 to 17-year-old Mexican-American kids, to watch the annual neighborhood re-enactment of the crucifixion. Every year, there was a long-haired Jesus, this year, performed by a former youth leader whose name was, in fact, Jesus. Well, Jesus. He wore nothing but a thorny crown on his head and a white bedsheet wrapped around his crotch.
务虚会的第二天是耶稣受难日，他们带我们，一群13到17岁的墨西哥裔美国孩子，去观看每年一次的邻里重演耶稣受难。每年都有一个长发耶稣，今年由一个名字恰好叫“耶稣”的前青年领袖扮演。好吧，耶稣。他头上只戴着荆棘冠，腰间缠着一块白床单。
About eight men followed around him, dressed in full Party City Roman soldier costume attire, with red capes and plastic helmets and whips they would snap at Jesus's feet, as he hauled a wooden cross three times his size around my neighborhood. A priest followed in the back of a pickup truck with a big loudspeaker to read each station of the cross. Local cart vendors were posted up, eloteros selling corn and raspados-- think Mexican snow cones.
大约八个男人跟在他身后，穿着全套派对之城的罗马士兵服，披着红披风，戴着塑料头盔，手里拿着鞭子在耶稣脚边抽打，他拉着一个比我社区大三倍的木十字架绕行。一位牧师开着皮卡车在后面拿着大喇叭读每一站十字架苦路。当地的小贩就在那儿，卖玉米的和小贩卖 raspados——想想墨西哥雪泥吧。
My favorite friend from catechism class, Crystal, who had edgy dyed red hair, but was never too cool to participate, walked with me and got some corn along the way. One of the youth leaders, José, noticed that me and the girl beside me didn't get one. He pointed at us and smiled. You guys don't want one, he asked. I got you. We shyly declined.
我在教理班最好的朋友克里斯托（Crystal），她染着前卫的红发，但从不觉得参与这种活动太没面子，她和我一起走，沿途买了些玉米。其中一个青年领袖何塞（José）注意到我和身边的女孩没买。他指着我们笑了。你们不想来一个吗，他问。我给你们买。我们害羞地拒绝了。
The teen leaders walked and talked to us, asked us what school we went to, which boys at the retreat we thought were cute. Crystal made fun of our catechism teacher, Jesse, one of the more stricter ones. Jesse was talking about the Ten Commandments and got to shall not kill, she said. Pena raised his hand and was like, isn't your brother in the Army? The whole class laughed, and he got kicked out.
青少年领袖们走过来跟我们聊天，问我们上哪所学校，我们觉得务虚会里的哪些男孩很可爱。克里斯托取笑我们的教理老师杰西（Jesse），他是那种比较严格的老师之一。杰西正在讲十诫，讲到“不可杀人”，她说。佩纳（Pena）举手问，你弟弟不是在军队里吗？全班大笑，他被赶了出去。
The teen leaders laughed, so Crystal and I were like, oh, they think we're funny. And so we kept going, running through all the other priests and directors. Someone shared their best impressions of Father Greg, our one white priest, whose Spanish was terrible-- he couldn't roll his R's-- and said that their mom doesn't go to the mass anymore when he's there because she doesn't understand him. Everyone laughed.
青少年领袖们笑了，所以克里斯托和我心想，噢，他们觉得我们很有趣。于是我们继续走，跑过所有其他的牧师和导演。有人分享了他们模仿格雷格神父（Father Greg）的最佳片段，我们唯一的白人牧师，他的西班牙语很烂——他没法卷舌——并说他们的妈妈再也不去弥撒了，因为听不懂他在说什么。大家都笑了。
We followed the procession all the way to the actual crucifixion at the top of a hill in Senka Park. And then suddenly, the mood shifted. The youth leaders seemed to straighten up. They got serious, stopped talking to us retreaters, and started whispering among themselves.
我们一直跟着游行队伍来到森卡公园（Senka Park）山顶的实际受难地点。然后突然间，气氛变了。青年领袖们似乎挺直了身子。他们变得严肃，不再和我们这些参加务虚会的人说话，开始窃窃私语。
We all need to get to the church ASAP, one of them said. They rounded us up once we were out of the park and started a head count. When we got back to the gym, the team leaders continued to be quiet. Everyone needs to sit down and form a circle around the room, a youth leader said, now.
我们要尽快赶到教堂，其中一个人说。他们带我们离开公园后把大家聚在一起，开始清点人数。当我们回到健身房时，团队领袖们继续保持安静。每个人都需要坐下并围成一个圆圈，一个青年领袖说，现在。
Retreaters whispered rumors of what could have happened. Maybe someone was ditching during the walk, or they caught someone smoking weed out of an apple from the snack table. Mauricio, the one adult supervising the retreat, walked into the room, looking down at the floor with his hands in his pockets. He stood in the middle of the circle and took his sweet time to look up at us.
参加者们窃窃私语，猜测可能发生了什么。也许有人在走路时溜走了，或者他们抓到有人在从零食桌上拿苹果抽大麻。毛里西奥（Mauricio），务虚会的成年监督人，走进房间，把手插在兜里看着地板。他站在圆圈中间，花了很长时间抬头看我们。
Lo que paso ahora...lo que paso afuera...fue absolutamente irrespetuoso.
What happened today, what happened out there, was absolutely disrespectful. Now saying this in Spanish really kicked things up a notch. The whole retreat was in English up until this point. And getting scolded in English was something we got from our teachers at school. But for kids like us, hearing disappointment in the language your parents spoke made it all much more intense.
今天发生的事，在外面发生的事，是绝对不尊重的。现在用西班牙语说这个确实让程度升级了。在此之前务虚会全程都是英语。被英语批评是我们从学校老师那里经常受到的。但对于像我们这样的孩子来说，用父母说的语言听到失望，让一切变得更加强烈。
He paced around the circle. He stopped again, shook his head at the floor. We were participating in the crucifixion of Jesus Christ, our Lord and Savior, who carried the weight of the cross to which he was destined to be nailed to, who took the whippings of the Romans. And his mother, our Virgin Mary, watched her son suffer for what? For all you to take a joyful walk in the neighborhood, to buy your raspados and eat your elotes and talk and laugh? His voice trembled, and he started to tear up. He had one hand over his eyes. He walked to the podium and grabbed a heavy crucifix.
他在圆圈里踱步。他又停下来，对着地板摇头。我们当时正在参加耶稣基督的受难，我们的主和救主，他背负着他注定要被钉上去的十字架，承受着罗马人的鞭打。而他的母亲，我们的圣母玛利亚，看着她的儿子受难，是为了什么？为了让你们在社区里愉快地散步，买你们的 raspados 和吃你们的 elotes，谈笑风生？他的声音颤抖，开始流泪。他一只手遮住眼睛。他走到讲台前抓起一个沉重的十字架。
Cada uno de ustedes debe sentirse avergonzado.
Every single one of you should feel ashamed, he shouted. How could you call yourself a child of God when you can't stand there with Him when He sacrifices for you, when He is suffering? He held the crucifix tight to his chest and continued to cry. It was my first time seeing a grown man cry in real life. He was out of breath at times in between the yelling and the crying. The room stayed still, and no one was making eye contact with each other.
你们每个人都应该感到羞愧，他大喊。当你不能站在那里与他一起，在他为你牺牲，在他受难时，你怎么能称自己为上帝的孩子？他把十字架紧贴在胸口继续哭泣。这是我第一次在现实生活中看到一个成年男人哭。他在喊叫和哭泣之间有时会喘不过气来。房间里很安静，没有人与彼此有眼神交流。
I quickly tried to recall the whole walk in my head and what I was doing, thinking, oh, shit, I was talking. Was I talking loud? Did I laugh? Damn, I did laugh. Panicked, I looked at Crystal to see how she was taking it. And I noticed tears were streaming down her face. She was still loosely holding the corn on the cob she bought. She got up, threw it out, and a bunch of retreaters began to do the same.
我快速尝试在脑海中回忆整个行走的过程以及我在做什么，心想，噢，该死，我在说话。我说话大声吗？我笑了吗？该死，我确实笑了。惊慌失措下，我看着克里斯托看她是怎么承受这一切的。我注意到泪水正流过她的脸颊。她手里还松散地拿着买的玉米棒。她站起来把它扔了，一群参加务虚会的人也开始这样做。
You see this? He held up the large crucifix and quickly walked towards the center of the circle. This, this is what you did today, he yelled. He slammed the crucifix at the center of the circle. I closed my eyes as ceramic hit the floor. It shattered, scattering pieces all over. There was a collective flinch and gasp. Mauricio walked out. It was like watching someone spit out the wafer you get at communion back into the priest's hands.
看到这个了吗？他举起那个大十字架，迅速走向圆圈中央。这个，这就是你们今天所做的，他喊道。他把十字架摔在圆圈中心。当陶瓷撞击地板时，我闭上了眼睛。它碎了，碎片散落各处。大家不约而同地退缩并倒吸一口气。毛里西奥走了出去。这就像看着有人把圣餐礼得到的圣饼吐回牧师手里一样。
I looked around to see a lot of retreaters' heads down, hearing disrupted breaths from crying. This girl, Karla, who went to the same middle school as me and was known to be somewhat of a troublemaker, was sitting right behind me. She took a deep sigh and with the exhale, let out a, what the fuck? Which, in a way, was exactly what I was thinking. Dude, be fucking respectful, said the boy sitting behind her. Dude, don't say fucking. We at church, said another whisper behind him. You just said it, Karla quickly snapped. A collective shh followed.
我环顾四周，看到很多人的头低着，听到哭泣导致的断断续续的呼吸声。那个和我上同一所初中并以淘气闻名的女孩卡拉（Karla），就坐在我后面。她深深地叹了口气，随着呼气，吐出一句，“搞什么鬼？”（What the fuck?），从某种程度上来说，这正是我想的。哥们，放尊重点，坐在她后面的男孩说。哥们，别说那个词（fuck）。我们在教堂，另一个人在后面小声说。你刚刚才说，卡拉迅速反击。集体一阵“嘘”声。
I turned and looked at Karla. She leaned in, smacked her lips, and whispered, man, they do this every year. Areceli told me. I couldn't even process it. So this is an act that they put on every year to make us feel bad? That seemed really unhinged. Every year, Mauricio cries, yells, and breaks a crucifix.
我转头看向卡拉。她靠过来，咂咂嘴，小声说，伙计，他们每年都这样。阿雷塞利（Areceli）告诉我的。我甚至无法处理这个信息。所以这是一个他们每年都会上演的戏码，为了让我们感到愧疚？这看起来真的很疯狂。每年毛里西奥都会哭、喊、摔碎一个十字架。
As I was trying to make sense of it, my neighbor, Sophia, who happened to be one of the youth leaders, walked to the center of the circle, microphone in hand, still crying. The other youth leaders took turns hugging her. Finally, she wiped away her tears. Don't worry, you guys, she said. She raised one of her arms up into the air, closed her eyes. Spanish gospel music began to crescendo in the background like a movie. I look over at the speaker to see a youth leader slowly turning up the volume knob.
当我正试图理清思绪时，我的邻居索菲亚（Sophia），恰好是青年领袖之一，拿着麦克风走到圆圈中心，还在哭。其他青年领袖轮流拥抱她。最后，她擦干眼泪。别担心，伙计们，她说。她举起一只手臂到空中，闭上眼睛。西班牙语福音音乐在背景中像电影一样渐强。我看向扬声器，看到一个青年领袖在缓慢地转动音量旋钮。
The rest of the youth leaders followed Sophia in closing their eyes, too. Slowly, the crowd of retreat kids, still sitting on the floor, did the same. Sophia opened her eyes and looked up at the ceiling. If we repent, He will forgive us. I looked up, along with everyone else.
其余的青年领袖也跟着索菲亚闭上了眼睛。慢慢地，坐在地板上的务虚会孩子们也做了同样的事。索菲亚睁开眼睛抬头看着天花板。如果我们忏悔，他会原谅我们。我抬头看，和其他所有人一样。
Pressed against the ceiling, I could see soccer balls that had been kicked too high and gotten stuck. I glanced around the room and at Crystal, who was right next to me. She was completely moved, listening and crying, transfixed. Was this the moment? Was this what they were talking about? And was this what I came for?
压在天花板上，我能看到足球踢得太高被卡住了。我环顾房间，看向就在我旁边的克里斯托。她完全被感动了，在听着哭着，出神入化。这是那个时刻吗？这是他们谈论的事情吗？这就是我来的目的吗？
On the walk home, I told my mom the whole story. She was surprised and thought the breaking of the crucifix was more disrespectful to God than the eating and talking during the reenactment. The part my dad couldn't get over, throwing away perfectly good food. He said that was a real sin, guilting kids into that.
回家的路上，我把整个故事告诉了妈妈。她很惊讶，认为摔碎十字架比起重演过程中的吃东西和说话，对上帝更不尊重。我爸无法释怀的是，扔掉完美的食物。他说那是真正的罪过，把孩子们引入歧途。
It didn't fully set in until that night, the lengths they had gone to, to play with our feelings. That a grown man thought it would be appropriate to pretend to be angry, that the teen leaders chatted us up, try to be cool with us, only to throw it in our faces and use it against us. I wondered how many times they could have possibly done this and how many kids never learned that it was scripted, or I guess, eventually did, when they became the ones who tried to pull this on others.
直到那天晚上我才完全明白，他们为了玩弄我们的感情走了多远。一个成年男人认为假装生气是合适的，青少年领袖们先跟我们聊天，想跟我们搞好关系，却只是为了在之后把它抛在我们的脸上，用来对付我们。我心想他们到底这样做了多少次，又有多少孩子永远不知道这是照本宣科，或者我猜，最终在他们自己成为试图对他人做这些事情的人时才明白。
I almost didn't go back the next day. But I, for real, did think, I might get my epiphany. I might get closer to God. I just needed to trust it more. And at the same time, a small part of me thought, this was just day two. How far are they going to take this? What other spectacles do they have planned? I didn't want to miss it.
第二天我差点没回去。但我真的在想，我可能会得到我的顿悟。我可能会更接近上帝。我只是需要更信任它。与此同时，我内心的一小部分认为，这只是第二天。他们打算把这个搞多远？他们还计划了什么其他的奇观？我不想错过它。
I wasn't disappointed. Day three was even weirder. When we all arrived at the gym, there were these tall wooden crates in the middle. Behind them hung a large white tarp. No one explained it to us. Instead, the youth leaders asked us about the times we felt like our parents misunderstood or neglected us.
我没失望。第三天更奇怪了。当我们都到达健身房时，中间有这些高大的木箱。它们后面挂着一张巨大的白布。没有人给我们解释。相反，青年领袖问我们什么时候觉得父母误解或忽视了我们。
Lots of kids stood up, and it got very real. One girl talked about how much her mom expected her to take care of her siblings, like they were her kids. Someone shared that he was gay, and he knew his parents would never accept it. It got to me. It got to all of us.
很多孩子站了起来，这变得非常真实。一个女孩谈到她的妈妈多么希望她能照顾弟妹，就好像那是她自己的孩子。有人分享说他是同性恋，他知道父母永远不会接受。这影响到了我。它影响到了我们所有人。
Then one youth leader pulled out a bucket of water balloons. They're filled with paint, she said. Throw them at the crates. Let out your anger and frustration at your parents. People hurled them, hard. Paint was everywhere. When they finished, the youth leaders went to the back of the crates and opened them up. Several parents stepped out, covered in paint. No one saw this coming. See? See what anger toward your parents does? This is what it does. Look at what y'all did.
然后一个青年领袖拿出一桶水气球。“里面装的是颜料，”她说。“朝箱子扔。发泄你对父母的愤怒和沮丧。”人们拼命地投掷。到处都是颜料。当他们结束时，青年领袖走到箱子后面把它们打开。几个父母走了出来，浑身是颜料。没人预料到这一点。“看？看对父母的愤怒会造成什么后果？这就是后果。看看你们都做了什么。”
The room got quiet. The parents looked somber. Some of them kept their heads down. Their kids ran up to them, sobbed in their arms, and asked them for forgiveness. Leaders told other kids to join them, and they did. I just stood there. I looked at the crates. And I could tell that the paint couldn't really seep through the small openings. They'd painted the parents before they even went inside.
房间安静了下来。父母看起来很忧郁。有些人低着头。他们的孩子跑过去，在他们怀里啜泣，请求原谅。领袖告诉其他孩子加入他们，他们也去了。我只是站在那儿。我看着箱子。我看得出颜料并不能真正从细小的缝隙里渗出来。他们甚至在父母走进去之前就把他们染上了颜料。
It was like yesterday was just a warm-up. There was a pattern, a formula they used. They invited us to be ourselves again, but this time, more fully. People were being vulnerable, and they used it against them. It felt cruel and dishonest and gross in a way I couldn't describe.
感觉就像昨天只是热身。他们使用一种模式、一种公式。他们邀请我们再次做真实的自己，但这次更充分。人们表现得很脆弱，而他们利用这一点来对付他们。这感觉残忍、不诚实，而且恶心，用我无法形容的方式。
Why did they set it up so that we'd end up feeling like we had to beg for forgiveness? It was like the only way they knew to bring us closer to God was to trick us. A part of me was still waiting for my epiphany, but now I was sure they wouldn't get me there. I'd have to get there on my own.
为什么他们要这样设计，让我们最后觉得不得不请求原谅？感觉他们唯一知道让我们更接近上帝的方法就是欺骗我们。我内心的一部分仍然在等待我的顿悟，但现在我确定他们不会让我达到目的。我必须自己去寻找。
Michelle Navarro is one of the producers of our show.
米歇尔·纳瓦罗是我们节目的制作人之一。
Well, our program was produced today by Sean Cole. The people who put together today's program include Jane Ackerman, Elna Baker, Chris Benderev, Zoe Chace, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Alix Spiegel, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
嗯，我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）制作。参与制作今天节目的包括简·阿克曼（Jane Ackerman）、埃尔娜·贝克、克里斯·本德雷夫、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、托宾·洛（Tobin Low）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特（Marisa Robertson-Textor）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Eugene Mirman, Kyra Welker, Kathryn Styer Martinez, Bridie France, Edgar Stephen Curo, Rebecca O'Connor, Jenna Chandler Ward, Fernando Pimentel, Stephanie Jenkins, and Barbara Dawson, who, by the way, recorded all those news clips we used in the Leprechaun story on her VCR long ago.
我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。今天特别感谢尤金·米尔曼（Eugene Mirman）、凯拉·威尔克（Kyra Welker）、凯瑟琳·斯泰尔·马丁内斯（Kathryn Styer Martinez）、布里迪·弗朗斯（Bridie France）、埃德加·斯蒂芬·库罗（Edgar Stephen Curo）、丽贝卡·奥康纳（Rebecca O'Connor）、詹娜·钱德勒·沃德（Jenna Chandler Ward）、费尔南多·皮门特尔（Fernando Pimentel）、斯蒂芬妮·詹金斯（Stephanie Jenkins）和芭芭拉·道森（Barbara Dawson），顺便说一句，她很久以前就在录像机上录下了我们在《鬼精》故事中使用的所有新闻片段。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows. If you're looking for something to listen to, there's tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过750集的节目归档。此外，还有视频。有最喜欢的节目列表。如果你正在寻找可以听的东西，那里有很多其他内容。再一次，thisamericanlife.org。
This is the last new program we are making with Ben Calhoun on our staff. Ben most recently did that two-episode story about a police officer and a KKK application in Muskegon earlier this year. But he also worked on our Harper High School show a few years ago, many political stories. He was a key player on that episode the won us the Pulitzer.
这是我们本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）在职期间制作的最后一个新节目。本最近制作了今年早些时候关于马斯基根一名警察和KKK申请的那两集故事。但他也曾在几年前参与过我们的《哈珀高中》（Harper High School）节目，许多政治报道。他是我们获得普利策奖那一集的关键人物。
And he did, I have to say, the world's most definitive journalistic treatment into whether pig bung is being passed off as fake calamari. Ben is a really good editor, which is rare, but good editors who are also great managers, like he is, even rarer. He's leaving to go run one of the most popular podcasts out there, The New York Times show, The Daily. They're lucky to get him. We will miss him a lot.
而且我必须说，他做出了世界上最权威的调查报道，关于猪肠是否被冒充成了假鱿鱼。本是一位非常好的编辑，这很难得，但好的编辑同时又是伟大的管理者，像他这样，就更难得了。他将离开去运营目前最流行的播客之一，纽约时报的节目，《每日》（The Daily）。他们得到他真是太幸运了。我们会非常想念他的。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I had this cake in the office fridge. And this afternoon, I went to grab a slice-- gone. Totally gone. Then I see Torey standing there with a couple of the producers, chocolate all over their faces, looking, I have to say, very guilty. Torey said to me--
《美国生活》通过 PRX 公共广播交流中心传递给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。我办公室冰箱里有块蛋糕。今天下午，我打算去拿一块——没了。完全没了。然后我看到托里和几个制作人站在那里，脸上沾满了巧克力，我必须说，看起来非常心虚。托里对我说了——
We just got back from a birthday party. We weren't even here.
我们刚从生日派对回来。我们根本不在这里。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。